there we have it they're the party of
excess oil and gas profits we're the
party of working people
mr speaker
talking
talking of parties
talking of parties prime minister
he told the house
no rules were broken in downing street
during lockdown the police have now
concluded there was widespread
criminality
the ministerial code says that ministers
who knowingly mislead the house should
reside
why is he still here
hang on hang on a minute
he just changed his position
i mean
we do it we do at least expect some
consistency from uh this this human
weather vein
it was it was only a week or so ago
where he was saying that i shouldn't
resign he's he's got to make what is it
what is his position mr speaker uh we of
course the of course the the the the met
musk the investigators must i must get
on with their job but in the meantime uh
uh let them and we and they should in
the meantime in the meantime mr speaker
we are going to get on uh with our job
and uh what we are what we are focusing
on is tackling the cost of living uh
helping people helping people uh through
the spike in fuel prices the 9.1 billion
that the chancellor has set out but also
mr speaking during the long i've
mentioned nuclear power i mentioned
tackling our energy supplies which labor
totally failed to do with what we're
also doing far more important perhaps
even than that mr speaker we're tackling
illiteracy and innumeracy in our schools
and i think we're investing billions in
tutoring mr speaker that's what we're
focusing on and i think that's what the
people of this country want us to focus
on
here's starman
look there are only two possible
explanations
either he's trashing the ministerial
code
or he's claiming he was repeatedly lied
to by his own advisers but he didn't
know what was going on in his own house
in his own office
come off
he really does think that it's one rule
for him and another rule for everyone
else
that he can pass off criminality in his
office and ask others to follow the law
that he can keep raising taxes and call
himself a tax cutter
that he can hike tax during a cost of
living crisis and get credit for giving
a bit back just before an election
when is he going to stop taking the
british public for fools
mr speaker this is the this is the
leader of the opposition who would have
kept this country in lockdown uh made it
absolutely impossible that you know he
has zero consistency on any issue uh mr
speaker but one thing we know about is
he would like to take us back into the
eu and take us back into long time if he
possibly could
thanks thanks to what this government
has done uh we have unemployment back
down to the levels it was before the
pandemic the economy bigger than it was
we have record vacancies mr speaker the
difference between them and us is is
they want to keep people mr speaker they
want to keep people on benefits we want
to help people into work and that's what
we're doing in record numbers uh they
want to raise taxes we want to cut taxes
and that's what we're doing and mr
speaker and we're tackling we're
tackling illiteracy they didn't give a
damn mr speaker and we're getting on
with making this country making this
country the best place to invest last
time i updated the highest mr speaker on
the number of unicorns that we had of
unicorns in this country that's tech
countries worth more than a billion
dollars mr speaker i said we had a
hundred i can inform you now mr speaker
that we now have 120 they don't want to
hear it but let me tell you
that's more than france that's more than
germany that's more than israel it's
more than france germany israel combined
mr speaker that's what's happening under
this government that's what's happening
because of the tough decisions we've
taken we take the tough decisions we
deliver they play politics mr speaker